everybody welcome to our glf my name is
Dan and today we'll be speaking about
the challenges and the pitfalls of
successfully implementing server-side
rendering also known as SSR in your web
project another way to put it is this is
all the things I wish we knew when we
implemented SSR at Wix
as a solution for all the websites
hosted on our platform indeed to a great
extent this talk is the result of all
the things that we encountered all the
problems that we had to overcome while
implementing server-side rendering at
works
so Bruce already mentioned my name is
Dan Dan Shapiro I've been with Wix for
five years more or less my role at Wix
is a performance tech lead which indeed
means that it's my responsibility to
make sure that sites hosted on the Wix
platform perform as quickly as possible
load quickly in response to user
interaction and indeed there are over a
hundred million websites on our platform
which makes it a not insignificant
portion of the web so I really like to
think that I can you know help make the
web a better place at least in terms of
performance okay then so you know when
you've been in with high tech for as
long as I've been doing software for so
many years you see that technology is
kind of like fashion in the sense that
what goes around comes around and
technologies that we used to have then
kind of fade away and then kind of make
a comeback so when I started doing web
development essentially all the web of
all dynamic web pages were rendered on
the server side you know a multi-page
applications or MPAs
so you had technologies like a PHP or
JSP or ASP all these three-letter
acronyms that all end in P for some
reason and then along came single page
applications and then suddenly we were
doing the rendering on the client side
we had frameworks like
amber and backbone and angular and the
webpage that was downloaded from the
server actually became essentially like
an empty page it literally had nothing
except maybe some you know the title and
then reference to some JavaScript and
then it performs some Ajax operation and
all the Dom all the HTML was essentially
constructed on the client-side and it
made it possible to create really
dynamic experiences that we came to know
a single-page applications or s paas but
now it seems that we are kind of coming
back to this approach of rendering at
least the first page on the server side
and it's not exactly the same as
rendering on the server which is why it
has this new name as a SAR server-side
rendering but there are a couple of
important differences and distinctions
between server-side rendering and as a
rendering on the server and SSR so one
important difference is this whole
concept with this terrible name called
isomorphic JavaScript where we are
essentially using the same code written
in JavaScript or compiled into
JavaScript both on the server side and
on the client side so we might be
running that code inside on the node
server on the server and then also
running that same code on the client and
the way that it works is that the server
code essentially generates the HTML for
that first page delivers it to the
client and then when the client actually
runs the same essential JavaScript code
what happens is this concept of called
hydration where thanks to technologies
like virtual Dom the client is able to
instead of rebuilding the HTML from
scratch effectively just hooks up event
handlers into this already pre-existing
HTML
so you get the the look and feel you
could say or the display from the server
and you get the functionality or
interactivity from the same code running
on the client and then from that point
on as you navigate through additional
pages on the client side then those
pages are essentially client-side
rendered like the you like you would do
in any normal single page application
now what are the benefits of this
approach so there are some benefits that
I didn't mention stuff having to do with
things like it's a bit better for SEO
even though search engines are getting
to be really good about being able to
process client-side JavaScript as well
and it's also beneficial in case for
some reason javascript is disabled on in
the browser which can happen but in most
cases the benefit actually has to do
with performance and there are several
reasons why performance with SSR
especially as it relates to time to
visible can be significantly better than
the performance with just client-side
rendering I won't go over this entire
list because this is not the focus of
the talk but just to mention a few so a
first obvious one is the fact that you
need to do to have fewer round trips in
order to get the visible content with
client-side rendering you download the
HTML and then JavaScript and then some
you do some Ajax or something so it's at
least two or three round trips whereas
with server start rendering it's just
that HTML that arrives another benefit
might be that your servers can be just
bigger and faster with more memory than
the client device especially if the
client device as is most common these
days is a mobile device it might be a
really low end phone and other reasons
as well okay then what's the impact so
it works when we actually implemented
server-side rendering for all the
websites hosted on the works platform
the performance gain was
really significant in fact of all the
actions that we took everything that
we've done in order to improve
performance over the past four or five
years this has been the most significant
change
as you can see improve performance by
something like sixty percent or another
way to look at it is that what used to
be the performance that only that was
the median is now it now it's what we
get with the 90th percentile and the
performance that previously only the 10%
of the users with the fastest
connections and devices used to get now
it's what half our users are getting so
the performance improvement was indeed
dramatic and we were very very pleased
with that but it turned out that it
wasn't really that easy
oh yeah but before that one more thing
another really useful thing about SSR is
that now it's really supported by
essentially all the main plots all the
main frameworks so whether you're using
react react was kind of the lead kind of
innovated that but right now it's
supported in view it's supported in
angular it's even supported in amber and
I'm sure that it's supported in other
frameworks as well so whatever framework
you're using you're basically kind of
getting this functionality so in other
words what not what's not to like you've
got it a support built in in the
framework the performance gain will be
huge I mean you know we should all be
doing SSR well it turns out that it was
definitely not that easy
in fact when I joined Wix 5 years ago
one of the first things we were already
then looking at as a star and it only
took us over three years to actually
succeed and like this boxer that has two
black eyes it actually took us two
failed attempts before we were actually
finally able to succeed with the third
trial and even that successful
implementation took us more time
requiring more resources than English
initially anticipated when I'm thinking
about the reasons of why
SSR turned out to be such a challenge to
implement the I like to group the
challenges into two main categories the
first one is our technical challenges if
all of you are well some of you're
familiar with the excellent article no
silver bullet which I highly recommend
just going out there and googling or you
can find the link here in my
presentation this is the concept that is
often known as accidental complexity
it's the fact that there are challenges
or problems or limitations that we can
overcome but it requires work and it
requires using the best and the most
appropriate tools then there are also
the inherent challenges these are
problems that are kind of built into the
problem domain that you can't really
eliminate they're there you can try to
mitigate them reduce their impact but
it's a challenge that you have to face
and this is often known as essential
complexity in the context of that
article that I mentioned so let's start
with the technical challenges and I'll
just go through a couple of them not all
of them domain ones um you know so we
were as I was saying you know you're
probably going to be implementing SSR
using some sort of a framework but and
I'm sure all of you are most of you are
already using a framework in your divert
in your web project regardless of
whether you're using SSR or not but and
it would seem that if you're using a
framework that you should be accessing
the browser Dom directly but the reality
is that we all know that we all do it
even though we're using some sort of a
framework somewhere in our code there's
a window dot something and if it's not
direct use of the dome then it's
probably something like jQuery and there
there are legitimate reasons for that
first of all obviously not all the
browser Dom API is exposed by most
frameworks so if I want to use some
functionality that's not really part of
the framework I need to access the Dom
also sometimes even with the best
frameworks it's just
makes sense to circumvent the framework
in certain cases special cases that we
all seem to encounter in our
applications and finally some of us are
just lazy and you say okay we'll just do
an inner tech innerhtml or something and
and and you know it just works but this
is a problem with with server-side
rendering is that obviously while you
can definitely use the browser Dom in
the browser you can't use the browser
Dom on the server because it just
doesn't exist if you try to do window
dot something on the server and node it
will explode you could put something
like JS Dom but obviously that's not
such a good idea because anything you do
will not actually get reflected down to
the client so you really want to not use
the browser Dom in your code when you're
using when you're doing SSR so what can
you do about it
well the obvious thing is to basically
eliminate it go over your code find
references to window dot anything and
just put pull them out but the reality
is as I said before is that in some
cases it's unavoidable and in those
cases you probably want to you what you
will need to do is you will need to
safeguard that access using something
like type of window different than from
undefined you'll probably want to wrap
all those Dom accesses in some sort of a
helper library that does these tests and
checks to make sure that your
application doesn't explode on this when
running on the server let's consider
another challenge this one is kind of
more insidious because it's not an issue
because the previous one was kind of
obvious you know you know you don't have
a Dom on the server
this one is more tricky and that's the
concept of the JavaScript context when
we running JavaScript in the browser the
browser creates essentially a new
instance whenever the page a new page is
loaded and when you navigate away or
close the tab the browser basically does
a cleanup for you even if you
just do an f5 to reload the page that's
a whole new clean context and what do I
mean by clean it means that all the
memory all the objects that you've
allocated in memory they're clean the
way they're removed and if you modified
various and Global's on the windows
object those are gone so information
from one session doesn't leak or make
its way into another session but that's
not the case when you when you're
running on the server side because well
obviously you could do something like
shutting down the node server after each
session and then starting it up again
PHP kind of did something similar or
does something similar between sessions
but you know that's not the way you work
you know you you basically want to reuse
the same node session instance between
between different sessions coming in
over the network and that means that the
same global variables for example will
get continued to exist so if you have
let's say a global variable that
contains some sort of a mutable value
that the session can actually write into
that global variable then that value
will actually the modified value will
persist into the next session and
obviously this can introduce all sorts
of security concerns privacy concerns or
just plain old bugs because you assume
let's say that the certain counter is
initialized to 0
but you end up with whatever it was at
the end of the previous session and this
could happen certainly when you're
running multiple sessions at the same
time but it can happen even happen when
you're writing running multiple sessions
sequentially within the same node
session so it means that global
variables in fact and and it's not just
global as you know variables defined in
a global scope it might be properties on
the global object it might be module
level global variables all these if they
are mutable
are not something that you can really
use inside a server-side rendering
solution so what can you do about it
well an obvious solution is to basically
just not allow mutable Global's but
that's obviously much easier said than
done because at the end of the day our
applications tend to have state and
state does change over time so one
approach that we found to be fairly
useful is to basically replace what will
be simple mutable Global's with weak
maps that we would keep based on a
unique session ID so every and the great
thing about weak map in this context is
that once that session is done then the
garbage collector is actually free to
collect all that memory and you don't
have to go explicitly through all these
Global's and release the memory you know
let me ask you a question it's kind of a
rhetorical question if your applications
say leaks 10 kilobytes per second is
that a lot is that a little well is it
is it a problem is it something that you
have to solve well it turns out that for
the client-side you could probably
ignore that because if a session let's
say lasts around five minutes in your
case then you've talked about a leak
that accumulates to around three
megabytes which is at the end of the day
something that we can probably live with
but in the server side if a server is
running continuously for 24 hours that
adds up to almost 1 gigabyte of memory
and that's not something that we can
live with so that ends up in us in a
scenario where you know you kind of have
to restart your node servers every
several hours because they are just
running out of memory and potentially
blowing up or starting or performance
really degrades so problems like that
that used to be non issues in
client-side become real issues in the
server side and and this is kind of a
mental challenge because with
client-side
you know if you deploy your application
and it seems to be running well after
the deployment in production and you
have enough users that actually play
with it and you see no problem let's say
an hour then you know you're probably
safe but with service start rendering
you're you're getting into this DevOps
world where you can get a phone call on
a Friday night at 3:00 a.m. that the
server has blown up because it's it's
leaking resources so that's definitely
something to watch out for so in coming
to grips with all these technical
challenges we really had to consider the
processes that we use and the tools that
we use and some of the tools are one of
the main tools one of the most
significant differences that that made
the difference between the successful as
a SAR project and the ones that failed
was that we went through a test first
approach in our case we had a
client-side rendering solution we wrote
a ton of tests that passed for that
client-side rendering solution and then
we made sure that when we went with SSR
all that whatever change we made all
these tests continue to pass so if
there's one key takeaway from here is
write a ton of tests and and just make
sure that they keep on passing turns out
that if Flint was a very powerful tool
or utility in our belt for successfully
implementing server-side rendering for
those of you are not familiar with it
yes lint is as a linter tool that
verifies that you're coding your java
script according to particular standards
and what's really cool about is lint is
that it's extensible so you can add your
own rules in our case for example we
added rules that checked for unguarded
Dom access or we added tools rules that
checked for the use of mutable Global's
and actually failed the build when when
there was such code in being pushed into
production this made it sure that once
we fix the code in order to work
successfully developers could not
accidentally check in code that would
cause problem in an SSR environment for
memory leaks it turns out that we
basically just had to learn more and
understand the various nodejs tools that
are out there
stuff like node inspector and all and
the various libraries and and tools that
you can use there's no getting around
that if you're going to be running your
software on node you need to have people
with no expertise on your team okay then
so all of these problems were technical
challenges now let's consider some of
the problems that are inherent to the
very approach of server-side rendering
so with client-side rendering the time
to visible and the time to our
interactive are essentially one in the
same that is you get a blank the blank
HTML page you run the JavaScript code it
generates that a to the HTML the Dom and
it's incidentally visible and
interactive meaning that if there's a
button you can click a button if there's
a menu you can select a menu item and so
forth that's not the case with SSR with
SSR these two become distinct SSR really
improves the time to visible because you
get that HTML with all the visible
elements really really quickly but it
turns out the time to interactivity at
best stays the same in fact from what
we've seen in most cases you actually
even experience some degradation so it
creates this scenario where you have a
visible user interface but it's either
non interactive or the best partially
interactive and I recently saw
presentation in which they mentioned
that Akamai did the research that shows
that if time to interactivity is more
than 30 percent longer than the time to
visible that induces range clicking
which means that if there are buttons
people actually start
because they're annoyed that nothing
responds to their interaction in other
words what you get here is not so much a
performance issue anymore it's it's
actually it's it's you could consider it
to be a bug a bug in the software you
have a user interface that the user is
trying to interact with and it doesn't
actually work now this is an inherent
problem because it's it's just a fact of
life this is what SSR does it improves
visibility it doesn't improve
interactivity so what can we do about it
we can try to mitigate it that is reduce
the impact of it so one approach for
example let's say you're using react in
order to render your user interface you
don't have to put all your react
rendering under one node you can
actually break it up and do rendering
under multiple routes so for example you
could split your page so that all the
part that's above the fold maybe going a
little bit below the fold is rent is
rendered with one route and the rest is
rendered with another and then you can
do like sort of this sort of hydration
in parts so you first hydrate the upper
part and then you hydrate the rest and
you can and with react now also
hydration can be interrupted
so if then somebody tries to interact
with the part that's above the fold that
will be already responsive while you're
still hydrating whatever is exists below
the fold but again this does not
eliminate the problem it only mitigates
it because for example if somebody
Scrolls down or even just loads the page
when they already scroll down they will
try to interact with components that are
at the bottom and it they will be
frustrated you know another benefit is
that in most cases people don't start
clicking right away because people tend
to look at the page before they start
interacting with it but still again if
if you're interactivity takes too long
then you definitely have a problem
another intrinsic problem is the problem
of diverges diverges what happens when
the HTML that's generated on the server
side is different either partially or
completely from the HTML that that was
that is going to be generated on the
client-side so it turns out that the
hydration process instead of just
hooking in the interactivity actually
has to replace some of the stuff that
was previously rendered on the server
now there are actually two reasons why
this might happen one is let's call it
unjustified diverges you can think about
them as bugs for some reason the code
running on the server is generating
slightly different HTML than the code
that's running on a client maybe it's a
timing thing
maybe it's the version of some library
you're using maybe it's just the fact
that it's an old environment rather than
the particular browser that that is
being used the way to work around that
is we built basically built-in tests
that do comparison of the HTML that is
generally received from the server where
the HTML that exists on the client after
the client finishes the hydration
process if the two aren't sufficiently I
equivalent then that is flagged as a bug
and it breaks the build so that's the
way to deal with unjustified diverges
but they are also justified diverges
think for example that your page has
let's say the timing date at at the top
left-hand corner of the screen and your
server happens to be in a different time
zone than your client then time will
obviously be different maybe even the
date will be different but even if that
doesn't happen time will pretty much
certainly be different when it's
rendered on the client and on the server
so that's a diverged that's not caused
by so much as a coding problem it's
basically
an unavoidable result of the design of
your webpage so in that case what can
you do the best way is to basically try
to design your page in such a way that
these kind of diverges don't occur and
if they're unavoidable then what we've
seen is that a better user experience is
to generally put in some sort of a
placeholder rather than putting in a
wrong value and then replacing it with
the right value after a bit it's kind of
disconcerting to see something like a
flash all of a sudden with a different
value so it could be like a spinner
maybe or even a blank area with no
content and that content is then later
filled in when the client does its own
work so to summarize what we've talked
about so far as we've seen SSR can
achieve a dramatic improvement in the
performance that your users experience
when they're visiting your website I
think you can all agree can all agree
that the 60 percent improvement in time
to visible is is very very significant
but on the other hand it does have its
issues it's not a trivial undertaking
it's it's not something that you can say
okay I'll I'm using react I'm using view
I'll just fire up a couple of note
servers and I'm done as I said before
test test and test again again if
there's one takeaway that you need to
either you should take from back from
this talk you know testing is always a
good approach we will have talks later
about testing in this in in YGL F but in
this context if you want to have a
successful as a SAR project that's what
made the difference for us that it was a
test first approach at building this
project second make sure to allocate
sufficient resources in time for it
again another difference between our
successful projects and the ones that
failed
is the fact that after having failed we
looked at why we felt a hey we didn't
allocate enough people we didn't give
them enough time let's let's do it right
you actually setup at a fairly large
team that actually worked specifically
on this project and we gave them all the
time that they needed and they actually
needed more time than was initially
given to them and remember that it's
inherent problem of this approach that
time too visible is going to be smaller
than your time too interactive and
you're going to have to face up to that
and and start your project and and
implement your project in such a way
that your that visitors to your site
don't consider it to be a bug because
your site simply is not responsive to
their interactions and essentially
that's what thank you very much
[Applause]